Transcriber: Mahmoud Mohamed Ahmed
المدقّق: Mohamed Salem
جيتا جيتو ابقوا لي قدام
انتو ضيوفنا و نحنا الخدام
هي جيتا جيتو ابقو لي قدام
هو هوي، جيتا جيتو ابقو لي قدام
جيتا جيتو ابقو لي قدام
انتو ضيوفنا و نحنا الخدام
و انتو ضيوفنا و نحنا الخدام
أنا الدومة عبدالله إبراهيم حسين
قصدت أنوا نقوم، إضاءات في الفلكلور
و التراث الشعبي في إقليم دارفور
إضاءات في الفلكلور الشعبي
و التراث الشعبي
الفلكلوري في إقليم دارفور
لمن نقول دارفور، يبقي دارفور
هي بتقع في جمهورية السودان
في الجزء الغربي
و هو المدخل الغربي بالنسبة
لجمهورية السودان
جنوباً، الجنوب الحبيب
ربنا يعاودوا لحضن الوطن
(تصفيق)
الغرب الجنوبي، دولة أفريقيا الوسطي الحبيبة
و الشمال الغربي دولة تشاد
و الشمال دولة ليبيا
و بحيطوا و بجاوروا مجموعة من
الأقاليم السودانية
شرقاً، ولاية غرب كردفان، و شمالاً
الشمال الحبيب
إقليم دارفور بتكون من مجموعة من
التضاريس، مجموعة من المناخات
جنوباً، السافنا الغنية، الجنوب الغربي
السافنا الفقيرة.
الشمال، بيئة صحراوية.
يتكون محتمع دارفور من
مجموعة من السكان
بتكون من مجموعة من السكان
ولمن نقول إقليم دارفور، يبقي
الإقليم الكان يوم من الأيام
دولة قائمة بذاتها. كان و من خلال
الدولة المرت
بدولة و إقليم دارفور تلاتة مماليك
مملكة الداجوا في جبال أم كردوس
و مملكة التنجو في شمال دارفور
و مملكة الكيرا أو دولة الفور أو
سلطنة الفور
و ده ما يأكد أنو شنو؟
ده جزء من شكل التباين
الموجود في إقليم دارفور
و كان الحكم، حكم فيدرالي
و هم أول من صكوا العملة
علي مستوي جمهورية السودان.
عملتهم إسمها الرضينة
و من خلال شكل التنوع ده عندهم
قانون، بقولوا ليه قانون دالي
قانون دالي مستوحاة من الفلكلور الشعبي
و العادات و التقاليد الشعبية و الدين
بتقسم إقليم دارفور الي قسمين:
قسم زراعي، قسم رعوي أو رٌحل
قسم رعوي أو رٌحل، نقوم نشوف
أهلنا المزارعين ديل
و كل الحضارات في السودان.
و في افريقيا قائمة علي الجانب المستقر.
لأنو الاستقرار عندو علاقة
بالحضارة و عندو علاقة بالثقافة
و عندو علاقة بالفلكلور الشعبي
لامن نقول المزارعين الهم
هم المستقرين و المهنة الأساسية
بالنسبة ليهم الزراعة.
و عندهم أجمل أغنية.
يقول ليك: “زراعة قومنا مشينا سويا
مشينا لفريق لمينا سويا
زراعة قومنا مشينا سويا مشينا لفريق لمينا”
وهم زراعة شنو؟ الدخن.
الدخن بكل مشتقاته.
الدخن والماليك وكل الحبوب.
هم
ثقافتهم قائمة على الرقص.
الرقص جزء اساسي وجزء اساسي من المزاج .
وجزء أساسي من الجو العام و
عندهم ثقافة المدي.
المدى.
كلهم بتلمو
مجموعات مختلفة، هم المجتمعات
المستقرة الزراعية دي.
عندهم لغات مختلفة .
لكن اللغة الوحيدة البتقوم تجمعهم
هي: اللهجة العربية.
أو اللغة العربية أو اللهجة العربية
و عندهم لغة جميلة كده
هي فلان جيتي، كيف حالك؟
منك كان دنيا
لهجة جميلة جدا، فيها حنان و فيها تحنان
(تصفيق)
عندهم ثقافة المدي.
المدي، بتلموا ديل
“هي بايا هي بايا
الله البني شقا”
في ناس برقصوا بنطوا لي فوق
في ناس “هي طيري فوق قميرية
طيري فوق شرك قبضا. هي طيري فوق
قميرية طيري فوق شرك قبضا”
و في ناس: “هي ساسا”
(يدندن)
الجانب الأدائي مهم جداً.
في المجتمع المستقر.
الإنتاج
الحرف اليدوية
والمواد العندها علاقة بالحرفة اليدوية
السعفية
أمامنا المندولة، القٌفة و دي واحدة من
مقترحات المرأة في دارفور
و هي المرأة الصانعة علي مستوي الأطعمة
و التحية
لمرأة إقليم دارفور، المياريم
(تصفيق)
لامن نقول المياريم هم صانعات أجمل طعام
في افريقيا، منطقة مليئة
بتجي تلقي المعفنات السبعة.
الكول و ما أدراك ما الكول.
ود ميسر، إسمو ود ميسر تأكلي
في يمين و تشمي بي أيسر
يقول ليك عفنوا في دارفور و
في  مصر كتل لي زول
فنوا في دارفور و في مصر شنو؟
كتل لي زول، ود ميسر
هو عشبة، بتقوم بتتخمر، و ده بيأكد ليك أنو
المرأة في غرب السودان أجمل ما يكون
علي مستوي الصناعة.
(تصفيق)
بسكنوا في القطاطي
الناس البسكنوا، أهلي ديل بسكنوا
في القطاطي، قطية، راكوبة
و القطية بكون فيها عنقريب
بكون فوقو نداية
بكون فوقو مشلعيب و بكون فوقو،
و مشلعيب ده بقول ليهو قال عدو كلب.
و بعداك ما أجمل الصريف و الرواكيب.
و أجمل ما يكون أنو المرأة في المجتمع ده
يكون عندها راجل بركاية،
جبراكة فوقو طماطمي
و فوقو فقوساي
و فوقو بصلاي
و فوقو لوباي
و هي ده بالنسبة ليها معين إجتماعي.
التحية للمرأة في غرب السودان.
(تصفيق)